[Music]
my name is Makayla I'm voting because
where I'm from in Texas extremely close
political race and I think every vote
matters
my name is Astoria and I brought him
because I want to be the change that I
wish to see in the world
my name is Carla and I'm not moding to
attend my legal status I've been here
for more than half of my life and I have
no rights my name is Harrison and I'll
be voting red in this midterm election
because the government has gotten to be
a little bit too swollen and there's too
much government spending and we need to
cut it down
my name is Patricio and I'm voting
because as a recently naturalized
citizen I didn't have the opportunity to
vote in the 2016 elections and I want to
use my new voice for those that don't
have like my name is safe and I'm not
voting because I did not feel
represented in the last election I'm
Elena
and I'm voting in this election because
I feel like I won the lottery by being
born in America where we have a
democracy and I give it damn I'm not
voting because I don't feel passionate
enough about any of the issues and I'm
voting because voting is our superpower
I'm not voting in the midterm elections
because I'm just busy hi my name is Cole
and I'm voting to keep Republicans in
power because I want to show that young
people are conservatives my name is Mel
moon and I'm voting because we need to
get Trump out of here
my name is Jude and I'm voting because
my duty as a citizen and a human being
to ensure a future for all people
my name is Maddie and I'm voting because
I'm from Arizona and there's an open and
contested Senate seat and I want my
voice to be heard my name is avery and
I'm voting to help those who have been
disenfranchised and use my privilege for
good
[Music]
my name is Christine and I'm voting
because I want to protect the rights of
so many women before me fought for Tom
Naveed and I'm a proud voter I'm voting
because it's my duty as a citizen to
vote and as an immigrant from
Afghanistan we unfortunately don't have
opportunities like this in certain
countries so if you're a citizen and if
you have the power to vote please go out
there and make a difference
[Music]